do you think death
mortality is fundamental to an agent
so like there's a i don't know if you're
familiar there's a philosopher named
ernest becker who wrote the
denial of death and uh his whole idea
and there's folks
psychologists cognitive scientists that
work on terror management theory
and they think that one of the special
things about humans is that we're able
to sort of
foresee our death right we can we can
realize not just as animals do sort of
constantly fear
in an instinctual sense respond to all
the dangers that are out there
but like understand that this ride ends
eventually yeah
and that in itself is the most is a
is the force behind all of the creative
efforts of human nature yeah that's
that's the philosophy
i think that makes sense a lot of sense
i mean animals probably don't think of
death the same way
but humans know that your time is
limited and you want to make it count
and you can make account in many
different ways but i think that has a
lot to do with creativity and the need
for humans to do something beyond just
surviving
and now going from that simple
definition to something that's
the next level i think that that could
be a second decision a second level of
definition that
um intelligence means something and you
do something that
stays behind you that's more than uh
your uh
existence um something you create
something that
is useful for others is useful in the
future not just for yourself
and i think that that's a nice
definition of intelligence in a
next level uh and it's also nice because
it doesn't require
that they are humans or biological they
could be artificial
agents that intelligence they could they
could achieve those kind of goals
so particular agent the uh the ripple
effects of
of their existence on the entirety of
the system
is significant so like they leave a
trace where there's like uh
yeah like ripple effects it's the but
see then you go back to the
the butterfly with the flap of a wing
and then you can trace a lot of uh like
nuclear wars and all the conflicts of
human history
somehow connected to that one butterfly
that created all the
the chaos so maybe that's not
maybe that's a very poetic way to think
uh that's something we humans in a
human-centric way want to
hope we have this impact
like that is the the the secondary
effect of our intelligence we've
had the long-lasting impact on the world
but maybe the entirety
of physics in the universe
has a very long lasting effect sure but
um you can also think of it what if
um like the wonderful life what if
you're not here
will somebody else do this is it is it
something that
you actually contributed because you had
something unique to compute
that contribute that's a pretty high bar
though uniqueness
yeah yeah so you know you have to be
mozart or something to actually reach
that level and nobody would have
developed that but other people might
have solved this equation
um if you didn't do it
but but also within limited scope i mean
during your lifetime or next year um
you could contribute something that
unique that other people did not see
and um and then that could change
the way things move forward for a while
so i don't think we have to be mozart's
to be
called intelligence but we have this
local effect that is
changing if you weren't there that would
not have happened and it's a positive
effect of course you want it to be a
positive effect do you think it's
possible to engineer in
to uh computational agents a fear of
mortality
like uh does that make any
any sense so there's a very trivial
thing whereas like
you could just code in a parameter which
is how long the life ends but
more of a fear of mortality
like awareness of the the way that
things end
and somehow encoding a complex
representation
of that fear which is like maybe as it
gets closer
you become more terrified i mean there
seems to be something really profound
about this fear that's not
currently encodable in a trivial way
into our programs
well i think you're you're referring to
the emotion of fear something
because we had cognitively we know that
we have limited lifespan
and most of us cope with it by just hey
that's what the world is like and i make
the most of it but
sometimes you can have a like a a a fear
that's not healthy
that paralyzes you you can't do anything
uh and
and uh somewhere in between they're not
caring at all and
and getting paralyzed because of fear is
a normal response which is a little bit
more than just logic
and and its emotion so now the question
is what good are emotions i mean they
are quite
uh complex and they are multiple
dimensions of emotions
and they probably do serve as survival
function uh heightened focus for
instance and fear of death might be a
really good
emotion when you are in danger that you
recognize it
even even if it's not logically
necessarily easy to derive and you don't
have time for
that logical detection a deduction you
may be able to recognize the situation
is dangerous and this fear
kicks in and you all of a sudden
perceive the facts that are important
for that and i think that's generally is
the role of emotions it
allows you to focus what's relevant uh
for your situation and
maybe if fear of death plays the same
kind of role but if it consumes you and
it's something that you think
in normal life when you don't have to
then it's not healthy and then it's not
productive
yeah but it's fascinating to think how
to uh
incorporate emotion into a computational
agent
it almost seems like a silly statement
to make
but it perhaps seems silly because we
have such a poor understanding of the
mechanism of
emotion of fear of uh
i think at the core of it is another
word that we know
nothing about but say a lot which is
consciousness
do you ever in your work or like maybe
on a coffee break think about what the
heck is this thing
consciousness and is it at all useful in
our thinking about ai systems
yes it is an important question
you can build representations and
functions
i think into these agents that act like
emotions
and consciousness perhaps so i mentioned
emotions being something that allows you
to focus and pay attention
filter out what's important yeah you can
have that kind of a filter mechanism
uh and you can it puts you in a
different state your computation is in a
different state certain things don't
really get through and others
are heightened uh now you label that box
emotion i don't know if that means it's
an emotion but it acts
very much like we understand what
emotions are
you